so I didn't film last night because I
didn't want to get a strike but I came
home at 4:30 just drenched in blood went
in here did this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
that thing was so gross
I had to wear it for so long it was so
ah ah-oh disgusting
can you imagine if MRSA woke up and she
saw me like that I probably should have
scared her
but didn't want to get a strike there's
even blood on my pillow
seriously yesterday I didn't get to show
you guys but I bought some cool stuff oh
[ __ ]
I really like this jacket it's
surprisingly cold in LA I think it looks
really good
I bought some candles yeah I'm that
level of hipster right now like if
someone told me that like two years ago
hey by the way in two years you'll buy
[ __ ] candles and ironically I would I
would want to punch myself myself from
two years ago would want to punch myself
but they smell so good though a very
nice shirt that I can't wear because I
have to wear this one another nice shirt
that I can't wear another knife and a
pair of pants hey I'll think I'll wear
them today oh yeah
these are cool net mini-drone you know
it was a huge investment but now I can
finally be cacey nice that once I get
this drone shots going Oh
Barda bo is gonna go to the next level
did I almost dad I almost died I I've
actually never dabbed in my life then
about this robot thing that I want to
test out as well so apparently these
bots is able to understand like
programming with lines oh my god oh my
god Wow
yeah I'm 12 what do you what do you want
so friendly this one has a camera on it
I can film I don't know yeah Wow
you wish you have this groan Casey you
wish you had this drone
again this is cool let me turn it around
if you're trying to run
let me back up I'm gonna apologize in
advance because I'm gonna be super busy
today that's why I'm just [ __ ] about
right now what up big what up that's
cool man that's really cool that's
really cool perfect landing oh oh [ __ ]
dawg
I might actually bring this out to just
take some actual shots if this camera
actually works alright I'm at Michael's
he forgot his sweater he knows I'm
coming but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna unlock one of his windows so the
next time I can sneak up on him
postmen ahh
[Music]
hi doing buddy bye Michael bye [ __ ]
hate that guy
I wanted Berta bow to be honest
vlogs not like a lot of vloggers who
pretend that everything is just so happy
and everything is so fun and then one
year later it turns out they want to
kill themselves you know I am I'm not
feeling great I am I was stressed out
before I went to LA I was thinking LA
would make me feel better and less
stressed I am I've never been this
stressed in a long time and I don't eat
I rarely get stressed it's just being
here I haven't I don't sleep enough I
don't have time for myself I sound like
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry it's just
when I don't have time to do my own
things I get really stressed out and
it's not a lot like I just want to spend
some time with Martina and I want to be
able to exercise I was like two
important things to me and if I don't
get to do that I don't feel very good I
get stressed out and now I got to do all
these things today and I won't have time
to vlog that's why I was doing all this
[ __ ] in this morning just to get some
stuff for the vlog which is fine but I
know I'm not saying you you should stop
blogging I love the volume the vlogging
is the best part of me being in LA so
far so don't don't take that away from
me I am just I think I need some time to
saddle in LA I think I haven't been able
to do that alright now I'm going to
drive for one [ __ ] hour because
that's everyone in LA pretends that
they're living in the same city when
they're not for some reason like you're
one hour away no you were not in the
same city you're [ __ ] far away far
off
[Music]
my dad made me lunch thank you
I also want to show you something really
cool yeah I'm finally a real vlogger it
films it's recording right now yeah now
we're going for a photo shoot I can't
say what it is but I asked for a tone to
be there what are you gonna do if they
don't give it to you I'm gonna be I'm
gonna go full Oprah where's my tote that
what she doesn't get it totes for every
woman
I guess I should have expected it to be
a weird shoot when I saw that house but
hey I got sleepy sleep it's mine
finally I miss you so much sleepy
[Music]
dramatic music okay we're at Michael's
place I left his window unlocked this
morning snipers here Chen is here we're
gonna sneak him and we're gonna give
that [ __ ] track wearing the shirt
he's run the damn [ __ ] damn it
[Music]
you can do you look at the before switch
3 2 1 never gasps never yeah
don't resist don't resist yeah yeah but
it's not too bad
like this is bad it was for Ethan you
made a lot of me let's dig a large Felix
thank you very much
yeah I love Jay Michael you love dick
well yeah what that was you can't walk
around like that got him got him
hell yeah yeah yeah
finally happened there was a girl
jumping in front of our gate try it with
her phone trying to take pictures and I
shut that [ __ ] down and then the mom
comes in to picture me hated cry I did
make apparently I made her cry but her
mom was there and she's like me baby and
I'm like well you should know better and
I feel bad but you can't come to a house
of the phone and you're an adult
if you come with your daughter like I
don't say like what are you gonna do if
you come here tomorrow there's like 20
people outside I'll shut that [ __ ] down
I'll shut that [ __ ] down anyway like I
feel terrible I genuinely feel bad about
having to do that but I also have to
draw a line and have and doing that is
it's too far it's just too far and I
hate it just don't come and this won't
be a problem that's the thing tell her
Tillery so any lover all right well if
to the girl that came I'm sorry if I was
mean but and I appreciate that you watch
my videos I don't know what do you say I
appreciate that you're you're you find
it in your heart to be that excited
about potentially seeing me just I wish
your mom would know better and tell you
no we're not going to go to his house
that's an invasion of privacy
hate to tell you this I found I found
all day but I got no I got no
interesting title what would be the
worst thing that we can do to get a
title like a hit by car blog type thing
but not actually getting hit by a car
we're just fake it
let's come up with the title real quick
what's the time I got hit by my own car
okay by my own car that's pretty good
hit by my own car we pretty good would
you click on that yeah hit my cars like
enough to click by hit by my own car all
right how do we do it we got to film you
tell me being hit by your own car but
not we just literally lay you down
how would phousi do it how could he do
it how does this look good it's kind of
look good man otherwise no one's gonna
click ok it's amazing I just need to
film enough and you got to get a good
frame in I know I'm trying it just
doesn't look like you can hit my car
looks like you've been eatin fire should
you take the picture with your phone
maybe this looks insane man like I just
looks really cool that's not people
don't click on music video I know don't
drive the car Brad oh that's good I like
reggaeton my thumb is in it I don't do
that [ __ ] kid en I can't I can film
icon do phone I got I got a piece so bad
can we get a finish up fast and that's
how you make a youtube video thanks Fuji
[Music]
Berta bo1 days are now five [ __ ] it goes
fast doesn't it
I'm having a lot of fun I hope you bros
are enjoying the vlogs leave it like if
you do I really appreciate it and thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
tomorrow with another Berta buh
[Music]